[Music]
foolishness is the price of
Genius organizations that create lots of
foolishness also create a lot of
Genius if you want to understand the
modern complexities in business
leadership and Society then here is a
new podcast from Stanford Graduate
School of Business I'm Kevin Co the host
of if then where we speak with
professors about their research in
everything from remote work to disaster
robot
you'll be surprised by what you learn
like what concert tickets teach us about
classical economics if Taylor Swift
concert tickets are allocated completely
based on competitive equilibrium or free
markets then people who are going to be
able to go to this concert are not
necessarily people who love Taylor Suite
the most or ways to navigate office
power dynamics there's strength in
numbers one person complaining about a
bad boss does not have nearly the same
protection or impact
as a group of people complaining about
the person all together if then digs
into topics that connect to our lives
our work and our future so the result
was that pairs that worked face to face
generated more ideas about 15 to 20%
more ideas than pairs of people that
worked on
Zoom if then is the new podcast for
Curious people looking for answers to
complex questions if you're one of them
then I hope you'll join us if then
launching January 24 wherever you listen
to
[Music]
podcasts